let's talk about Star Wars being
officially over you ready for this not
over you didn't see the last it's over
dude you know didn't LucasArts just say
that they're gonna start something from
like 200 before 200 years before the
first it's dude dude it's done I don't
like this I'm let go listen I don't know
let me show you the no I refuse I roll
star wars confirms Ray's father is a
failed Palpatine clone just wait when I
start breaking this down for you okay
because you're gonna be like wait what
well I didn't know the whole thing with
again I haven't seen the newest don't
worry so if have you said if you have
seen it he's gonna spoil it for me and
you okay
have you seen their warrant have you in
the prequels I just felt like I needed
and you saw the original I saw they were
trying let's do this the Star Wars the
rise of Skywalker novelization reveals
Ray's father was actually a failed
Emperor Palpatine clone the sith eternal
built i got so many questions let's read
the novelization reveals this we get it
it reveals in the film that raised the
emperor's greta in the film one of the
biggest reveals that rey is the
emperor's grand daughter descending from
ultimate evil while rise of skywalker
director JJ Abrams and co-writer Chris
Terrio have done their best to explain
with his plot to twist as compelling
some viewers took issue with how it's
seemingly retcon the last Jedi stance
that Rey came from nowhere and her
parents were nobodies the rise of
Skywalker tries to quote from a certain
point of view its way around this but it
didn't work for everyone hold on wait a
minute so the last Jedi I didn't even
believe that that was the case you
shouldn't you should should be an issue
of you believing or not it's a movie
telling you a story yeah I know there
was a lie to you I know but even in the
movie you know you know he's like oh I
searched her mind and your parents were
nobodies and it's like he was also
trying to antagonize her and get her to
like give in to the dark side kind of
things like like the whole movie was bad
writing
but hold on hold on let me point
something I don't know if it was
necessarily bad right oh dude you're the
minority man maybe it's like everybody's
screaming about how bad it is there's a
new subreddit that emerged after people
were like what is this one the last Jedi
rise of Skywalker
both of them in the last Jedi you know
the plot is what a space chase where you
run out of fuel
and your vehicle slows down there's a
thing called inertia in space they tried
to explain it away oh it's actually that
they're slowly accelerating the whole
time okay fine
make make it up but then literally in
the last Jedi they find a guy and their
secret plan was to exit the ship in
escape pods while the bad guys weren't
looking out the window
I know you're right you're right and
then the bad guy can we put a blind that
is and then my bubbles are being popped
listen Benicio del Toro's character is
like I've betrayed you
bad guys look out the window and they
look out the window and go oh and they
see the ship escape I'm looking what
don't have sensors like what is this
garbage and then apparently recently
recently Rian Johnson came out and said
that he didn't care anyway he's like I
don't care about the history of the
universe it was matter to me it's like
wait how do you make how do you make a a
sequel it doesn't connect to the ones
before it but let's talk about Palpatine
okay first of all bunny first of all I
can see I concede your points though
here's the first right here's the first
problem with rise of Skywalker who was
Palpatine hooking up with ya who would
want to hook up with us now somebody
apparently but here's maybe he made a
clone of someone who's interested now
hold on hold on this is we're we're
clearly in declining this has just
completely destroyed the entire Star
Wars continuity I am not exaggerating
when I say that yeah and it's not even
right now it's with Palpatine coming
back in the first place which I'll get
to but this really was the nail in the
coffin first of all I think what they
did was they found out that people were
mocking the film laughing about who
Palpatine was bangin to make a baby
right and so because of that they tried
working their way around it like no
you're the clone he made a clone who had
a kid so he did and then in the book
they apparently claim like Palpatine's
first clone who was raised dad was a
failure with no force powers so
Palpatine was like oh he's worthless and
so they wouldn't have getting you know
like had him killed
he escaped oh sure so he escapes with no
method i powers with okay and has a
family but then why did Rey inherit Jedi
powers how did that happen I don't know
because they said that you can inherit
midi-chlorians that's why lose more
powers is the mom oh well there's a
mother yeah her parents yes
she has no grandmother well it says the
Emperor's granddaughter so that means
that was the movie and a retcon in a
movie now she's actually the daughter of
Palpatine but a clone of his here's the
best part they explained it the reason
he made the clone was because he always
knew Vader would betray him and so he
prepared an emergency plan and get this
as he was being thrown down that you
know I don't know vent or whatever he
used dark force powers to send his
consciousness to the body of a different
clone which also makes no sense because
he's deformed because mace window to
waste a window deflected the Lightning
from the saber rack at his body yeah
melting his skin and everything now some
people have explained this as no that
was an illusion he's always been looking
this way okay but hold on at the end of
rise of Skywalker the decrepit Palpatine
who's like hands are all withered steals
the powers from Ray and and and kylo and
heals himself I don't get it he's in a
clone body yeah he made an old clone
version of himself yeah now here's the
best part why would Anna go Anakin was
the chosen one right mm-hmm who was
supposed to bring balance to the force
yeah never killed Palpatine prophecy
never happened it was never fulfilled
right so the entire the entire sequel
prequel a prequel truly reckoned yeah
that was by bringing him back man you're
ruining Star Wars for me
no they ruin Star Wars for me well he
was fine until you told me I had enough
so so hold on when they first made that
Palpatine survived it did break the
prophecy from the from the earlier
versions but when they made the new the
new story yeah that basically says that
he always suspected Vader would betray
him
it completely erases the Anakin story
sense to me if he always knew he would
have had Vader killed right if he was a
true Sith Lord like what you're gonna
betray when when Vader when Vader's back
was to him if you always he'd be like me
and you would Electric invader boom and
then like he did with the would actually
rage and maybe turn to the dark side now
here's the best part
here's the best part this isn't this
there's
or well this is we're sort done with
this particular issue but did you know
that right now it is canon in Star Wars
that the Emperor survived and is
inhabiting Ray's body inhabiting yeah
her body I mean so Rey's evil now well
so here's the thing at the end of rise
of Skywalker he goes strike me down and
my essence will flow into you
completing the ritual or something like
that right oh goodness and she's like no
and then she strikes him down like wait
wait wait what and she also executes
it's a ton of people this is crazy I
noticed this when I first watched rise
of Skywalker hmm there's a bunch of
people chanting and screaming in the
background
yeah like worshipping Him yeah and she
she she kills small dude she wipes them
all out so she is evil I think so so
here's what I think happened here's
based on the rules they set up when the
emperor literally says if you strike me
down in anger my essence will flow into
you come join the ritual or whatever
okay and then she does
I was like wait what in return to the
Jedi he's like no and he like throws the
saber down or whatever like I won't do
it an invader is the one who kills em
right Luke refused to do it he refused
to act out of anger and join the dark
side yeah she did
she's don't mind the dark side well so
technically then did his essence flow
into her and then some people are saying
like at the end of the movie she buries
Luke's saber
okay then starts claiming she's a
Skywalker when she's not she's a
Palpatine so the the the fan joke now of
course it's not really canon like the
Disney's never gonna run with it but the
joke Canon is now that well she did what
he said just strike her not an anger so
clearly she must be possessed now by
Palpatine who was a young woman I guess
now I did kylo make it no he's dead not
he made out with her or something
like it did for no reason their way to
say there was nothing remotely sketchy
about this they just kissed passionately
for a moment at a weird time thanks guys
so here's what it says during the scene
in the rise of Skywalker novelization
when Ray is feigning taking part in the
Seth Riggs at all to trick Palpatine
right before she passes the lightsaber
to Ben she has visions of her
grandfather's past the passage in the
book reveals after Return of the Jedi
Palpatine thrust his con
justice into a clone body however the
transfer was imperfect and members of
the Sith eternal works tirelessly to
engineer a new vessel for Palpatine's
essence one of these attempts is
described as a useless powerless failure
who was quote not a quite identical
clone with this while this body wasn't
fit to house Palpatine's power it was
still able to live and eventually become
raised father back in January Rises the
Skywalker editor mary and brandon
revealed they cut additional Palpatine
backstory in an effort to condense the
film and it's possible this information
is what she was referring to no lies no
way so there's actually an article here
from Forbes here are all of the rise of
Skywalker retcon reveals so far dude
they just made this movie it just came
out and they're already trying to
retroactively Lee alter fix it all yeah
that's how bad it is we're done Star
Wars it's over yeah okay go ahead we'll
get into that in the rise of Scour
because you didn't see it
fin at one point like they're about to
die or something and he goes right I
need to tell you a secret and everyone
assumed the secret was a deal of DeRay
yeah well apparently now they're saying
is that he was going to tell them that
he was yet forced powers I guess they
say JJ Abrams stepped in to answer the
question directly claiming that fin was
trying to tell ray that he could feel
the force just like her call me a
conspiracy theorists the guy writes but
I just don't believe in especially
considering that fin was implied to have
a crush on Rey in the force awakens
there is in the movie he's they're like
they get sucked underground from like
quicksand or something you know and then
he's like ready to tell you something
I'd tell you something and then once
they realize they're okay
she's like what he didn't tell me he's
like I'll tell you later nothing ever
happens he never says anything just the
movie like movie goes on the movie ends
never gets resolved that's kind of odd
right and what people have been saying
is it was obvious that the film was
likes kragle together and mashed like no
one had any idea was going on you know I
love though I got to give Rian Johnson
credit for this he made a bold move in
completely destroying the franchise by
killing Snoke because yeah I was kind of
shocked when I when that happened that
was subvert expectations but you realize
you got rid of the antagonist there's no
one left now yeah and so that they're
like we'll bring
palpatine I guess completely destroying
every film before it
he was my let's uh there's a little bit
more here so this is a lot of I would
have liked to see Darth Maul's top half
on like a robot spider well that was the
extended universe that would've been
cool I'm pretty sure in the extended
universe I really lighted Darth Maul
he's playing they got rid of all of it
they got rid of the Senate universe so
there's uh
Lando's DNA tests they mentioned that
Lando and Gianna she's a stormtrooper
who like helps them they go on adventure
together afterwards manure movie yeah
yeah yeah it turns out it's like it's
his daughter okay that wasn't in the
movie but sure here's the best part the
massacre of the innocents
when Palpatine reappears the audience is
expecting him is expecting him but
doesn't know how he came back the
canonical answer is that Palpatine ships
were built and piloted by brainwashed
slaves the natives of EXA call doomed to
be slaughtered in the final battle
between good and evil this detail fills
in a pretty gaping hole Star Destroyers
require a massive amount of resources to
build so it was strange that Palpatine
had so many to spare where did he show
up with like a whole bunch of them dude
it's insane it's like thousands
seriously yeah how do that it's called
Davis ex machina God from the machine
they just write it they're like yeah
there you go as a Palpatine he's got
ships yeah
so check out the retcon completely
changes the way we view the final battle
as tragedy now sours the great victory
in hindsight our heroes made the choice
to slaughter uncountable innocence
brainwashed by the Sith into doing their
bidding in order to defeat Palpatine
again and that note the way the sequel
trilogy frames stormtroopers is
unwilling slaves makes all of those
casual kills seem pretty cold especially
coming from Rey and Finn who should who
really should know better yeah clones
all the way down and then they talk
about you know Palpatine and then clones
and ever yeah raise no no no that's
different okay so it's basically the
same thing raised new father ray and
Kyle Oh kissing means nothing in the
book they kind of just got rid of it but
congratulations Disney you've done I
gotta say I'm impressed
you have effectively destroyed
everything I'm pretty impressed too it's
it's crazy how they can mess up so badly
well the way I really like this comment
it's cut it's from one of the subreddits
talking about this hmm they called it
the cargo cult Star Wars oh yeah so for
those that aren't
with the cargo cults basically I think
it was World War two us and I think
Japanese we were using islands in the
Pacific Pacific Islands to store
supplies and refuel planes and stuff the
natives on these islands had no real
contact with with other you know more
advanced cultures so they saw these
planes in didn't know what they were and
started building effigies of the planes
and worshipping them thinking they were
gods or something so there's literally
like a bunch of people like worshiping
what looks like a plane but it's made
out of twigs and bamboo and stuff
thinking that would bring them back you
know it's called the cargo cults and so
what they said was this is that what
Disney has done is they were all looking
down at Star Wars this great franchise
flying around in these great things and
so they took a bunch of random parts
mash them together thinking it with Star
Wars
it looks like Star Wars or someone who's
you know has no idea what plane works
and they didn't actually make real Star
Wars yeah they made weird movies that
have nothing to do with each other about
people no one liked with crazy powers
that like Rey in in the rise of
Skywalker grabs a spaceship and holds it
and then shoots with lightning it blows
up oh wow like she's powerful even Yoda
lifting the the the x-wing is going like
with both his hands yeah and she's like
fighting over it with Kyle electronic
I'm like that's a giant ship in the sky
like I just seem so dumb but none of
them really cared no they just you know
it's weird to me
they bought a property and then totally
destroyed it but you know it is really
weird to me why hasn't anyone else been
able to create a cinematic universe
outside of Marvel hmm it doesn't seem
like it's a hard thing to do yeah well
coming up with original stuff isn't what
no no they don't have to you could take
something out of a book and you could
you could take a written series and turn
it into a universe like that well look
at look at look at what DC has done with
the movies they made bad movies but
here's the thing it's the movies weren't
completely bad there's kind of bad I
mean bird of prey birds of prey was like
nightmarishly bad yeah so that squad was
kind of bad but you know just Lee was
okay Batman for supreme I was like yeah
I don't understand why so we had the
dark universe from that was the
universal crib you know it was the bomb
you know the movie The Mummy with
Cruz was supposed to be like the start
of a dark universe I would love more
those that'd be awesome that was yeah
they want they want to do mummy
Frankenstein dr. Jekyll mr. Hyde and all
those original Universal Monsters and
Tom Cruise ended up as like some awesome
mythical like Egypt right yes set
whatever yeah right but under control
what's cool the movie didn't do as well
as they wanted so they decided to scrap
the idea or whatever that's a shame I
thought it was cool but when you look at
what DC did they tried to like race
Marvel to their big right Avengers like
marbles doing Avengers so I thought we
better do Justice League now it's like
maybe you should make a flash movie in a
Wonder Woman movie and leading up to the
Justice League
like Marvel did yeah you know we don't
so copy them every step of the way but
the big ensemble cast of the Avengers
was after everyone knew and loved the
movies right and it gave Marvel the
opportunity to be like here the
characters that will work yeah these
movies did well okay now we've cleared a
runway so we can actually launch this
big you know blockbuster hit yeah
instead DC made some movies that people
didn't really like and then I mean Green
Lantern remember that with Mike with
Ryan Reynolds and I was actually really
bummed about that cuz Green Lantern is
one of the comics I did read I liked
Green Lantern but he wasn't a good movie
it wasn't the worst movie it wasn't the
right movie you're right
you know I like it I like Ryan Reynolds
great I like an indent well when he's
like you know he gave me a super suit
don't make it green or animated yeah
that was awesome awesome but but he has
tried yeah I don't understand where they
can't do it yeah and they took a
universe star wars one that has a
massive fan base going back decades and
they were handed this this beautiful
beautiful apple pie the do the other two
Disney do rogue one I think yes I think
that they did it was it I liked I liked
rogue well me too and it's what it's one
of really good I think rogue one is the
most popular Disney era Star Wars film
have you seen solo no I couldn't do it I
liked solo I heard it was okay
actually someone told me it was pretty
good yeah it's it's better than these
movies I can't wash it and I told you I
liked these I tried watching it and I
got ten minutes and I was just like it
hurt oh so low yeah
because I have seen the beginning could
be seen as it's not it's not it's not
that it's just like after watching the
last Jedi
I give that movie a zero I wanted
Scarborough oh right oh right so
Skywalker was sad for me you know why
come on
because I was watching it going like I
see what they could have done when JJ
Abrams came bad did this not me I don't
make a movie when I say it him to know
what they would could do better though
yeah but I I think I know everything so
you know what does that really value no
I don't I don't think I could make a
better movie then I could make a better
movie than Rian Johnson I wouldn't want
to sit around writing all that though I
don't care to do it yeah but I think I
think you could take a random guy off
the street and be like here's Star Wars
give me an idea and to give you a better
idea than Rian Johnson so raise nothing
snow dies they're hiding like their
escape plan is to not look out the
window cut the window it sounded like he
was angry that he wasn't gonna be doing
the third movie he's like that's no I'm
just gonna finish it here in the second
movie no I think he says in the film let
the past die kill it if you have to oh
yeah kylo actually says it right and I
think he was telling the audience and
and you know what we're tourism killing
it but listen reading so this is a
conspiracy theory uh-huh and if it's
true I actually respect it you know why
all we've been doing is taking old
things and remaking them it's true it's
remakes it's it's it's it's you know
reimagining x' yeah it's adaptations
annoying so how many how many
transformers are we all now we're on one
facet if you're is nine plus like three
spin-offs or some ridiculous number so
he said here's my chance
he killed the antagonist without
explanation no one with no with no
character developing it's like he's gone
well why would Disney want that though
they're stupid they let a wolf in the
henhouse man that's sort of and he and
he rubbed his hands he was like oh yeah
it's time to destroy Star Wars and he
did yeah and he did and there I can't
believe they're people who are like on
Twitter defending it saying it was the
best movie ever made or whatever it
they're like this is the best Star Wars
ever made and I'm like I think what was
your favorite was the Mary Poppins scene
where where
Leah's like floating through space oh
yeah you know or was the fact that
literally everything in the movie
happens for no reason no he was probably
a trek fan and hated when Star Wars came
out as all of his friends were like no
way Star Wars is way better than Trek
and he like lost all his friends and
he's he's kinda I'm gonna maintain my
Star Trek is better than Star Wars I I
actually like them both for the record
but yeah I use like he's like now's my
chance like you're saying like oh yes
I'm gonna destroy you know what man Star
Wars now if that was good I haven't seen
that knives that was good I was
impressed it was great cool Chris Evans
was good in it yeah I thought they I
thought it was well written oh cool and
looper was good but like Luke oh is this
what he's yeah yeah yeah right right
okay I liked looper but it also doesn't
really make sense looper yeah like a
movie it's got like cotton the
continuity doesn't make any sense but it
was fun anyway
yeah but knives out III ended up going
to see it because the ratings were 100
percent you know even from the audience
oh wow and so I was like dude if they're
people who have seen this movie knowing
and hating him for Star Wars I was like
I think I got to go see it I saw it and
they're definitely some like social
justice he type tropes in it no guy but
for the most part I think they poked at
everybody and I think he did a good job
with it which makes me believe he killed
star was on purpose yeah when when I
first heard he was gonna be doing Star
Wars I was actually oh wow oh cool cuz
he did that sci-fi stuff you know the
looper oh okay and then I saw it now is
just sitting there like twitching with
my drool coming down what am i watching
I wanted to walk out I wanted to walk
out when I got to the part so there's a
part in the last Jedi where they get
captured and they're in the Star
Destroyer from the first order and
they're about like they're about to
execute Finn or something when all of a
sudden hold oh does the Lightspeed
maneuver where she launches the ship
through the Star Destroyer and it's like
a streak of light oh yeah okay and then
when it comes back to the Star Destroyer
all the stormtroopers all the
stormtroopers are gone and phasma who
was standing next to Finn is now on the
other side of the room
oh yeah that's and I was like what how
does that happen what just happened
right it like makes no sense it was like
the way I described it was if someone
did a but a vine compilation of seven
second clips
somewhat related to Star Wars then just
edit them all together see I know I was
watching these movies as a huge Star
Wars fan
blindly putting my blinders up to all
the things that you've you've shown me
tonight and I can see them now and I'm
like he's right I think you went in is
just like not thinking about it yeah it
sounds like like eat popcorn inch bug
yeah that is it that is exactly I when I
see it in the theater I want way later
and I was like oh yeah okay I went in as
a total nerd as a total geek being like
Star Wars The Force me chlorines and I'm
watching like no basically I'm a dude
I'm the comic book guy from The Simpsons
okay not not the fat one the one who
goes to the panel the presentation by
Krusty and he goes excuse me in episode
you know s 921 yeah it she hits scratch
or you know it she hits Scratchy's
ribcage twice but produces two different
tones are we supposed to believe this is
a magic ribcage of some sort I'm that
guy no I'm not the worst but I am
definitely nitpicking but in general it
was a bad movie no I think it's fair to
say there are a lot of people who don't
care about Star Wars mm-hmm they don't
like I mean I played Knights of the Old
Republic when I was when I was younger I
played
Jedi Jedi Knight one and two love those
games and so I'm like excited for the
new movies I'm not the biggest fan in
the world force awakens I thought was
okay but come on it was a shot-for-shot
remake of a new hose it was but then in
the last Jedi I was just like I don't
even what I'm watching yeah yeah let me
ask you which is worse the rise of
Skywalker or bird of prey or I'm sorry
Harley Quinn Oh Harley Quinn handler
down yeah so here's the thing about rise
of Skywalker hmm I there were actually
it was up and down for me and it made me
sad whenever there was a good moment
because I'm like if they--if style I
said I wasn't bad they could have really
had something here you know it was you
know but I gotta say man like when she
grabs the ship and like is controlling
it she has force healing powers she like
it's just so ridiculous well she has she
has Palpatine's power so you know
technically he said if you strike me
down this will happen and then she did
so I can only assume right now at least
in my mind she is Palpatine yeah
gratulations
Palpatine has transfer his consciousness
into a so really British woman is now
the ultimate Seth yeah
all right that's it thanks for checking
out this segment from the Tim cast IRL
podcast we do the show every Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. sometimes an
hour or two and we do have a full live
recorded version of the show that
includes a lot of comments and smaller
segments you probably don't see if you
want to check that out you can watch
live at 8 p.m. Monday through Friday or
become a member of this channel and for
five bucks a month you get full access
to all of the recorded podcasts every
day after the show we make them
available in the community section of
this YouTube channel so don't forget to
subscribe and stick around for more
segments and more shows Monday through
Friday at 8 p.m. thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all in the next show
you